the staff need to understand the true
meaning of hospitality this place is
definitely the road to recovery but I
think this team needs some training so
I've asked a very special friend Ramesh
said wali from Caesars Palace to
actually show them how it's done
hi Gordon good to see you how are you
come on Dean how are you oh great please
take a seat it's so nice to see it's
great to see you
so the customer focus is critical is
this very nice and in your mind what are
the golden rules in the first 60 seconds
you have to approach against with a big
smile on your face because I just opens
all kinds of doors find little ways to
to make a lasting impression on that
guest and let them know that their
comfort and their enjoyment is your
primary objective and it sounds simple
but it's not that simple in a few
practice all the basics the rest of it
will just fall into place there has to
be natural people know when you're not
being sincere the good news is the team
here you know their half is in the right
place but they are clearly lacking
training yeah the owner doesn't smile
that often so okay all right let me go
get the team okay thanks for mesh
Kennedy got someone very special one to
introduce you to please come true I'd
like to introduce you to a very very
dear friend of mine please my name is
Ramesh
Ramesh nice to meet you he's from
Caesars Palace he's flown in from Vegas
I asked Ramesh to come and teach you how
to greet customers
holy mackerel here's a guy that runs
Caesars Palace coming to teach my staff
how lucky of a guy am I he's here to
help you and to show you within 60
seconds of those guests arriving through
that door what we need to hit first
impressions go wrong they never forget
it okay why don't we have a look at what
they normally do
stop straightaway and we restart okay
stop as soon as you see a guest coming
through there you can come out here and
reach for the door open the door and
have a big smile on your face you look
like you just lost your arm here we go
bollocks
okay put a lot more into it okay it's
got to be good afternoon it's great to
have you here welcome it was kind of
hard I'm gonna work to get better at
greeting people
good afternoon nice to have you here
welcome to the river rock in thank you
very much
stop before he extends his hand out to
you you should have extended your hand
out to I feel like I'm being yelled at
by a drill sergeant you're out almost at
parent your target Karen you have a
incredible smile Gordon's in the back of
these chanting you know you could do
this you could do this no one give it a
pep talk here we go good afternoon I'm
Karen welcome to the river afternoon my
name's James Sanfilippo I'm here to
check in welcome mr. Sam Filippo
come right this way I see that you'll be
staying with us for the next week
yesterday I'm possibly more of of course
that would be wonderful we have you
staying in our king-size room which is
on the second floor absolutely lovely
room with a pretty view at the front of
the house so that's a nice place to be
nice Karen is a super store she really
is that way very well done Gordon helped
me realize that I have people that I can
rely on and instead of being the
hands-on owner I should be more of the
overseeing owner which I really need to
be rights
[Music]
now that Ramesh has taught the staff how
to make the right first impression I'm
gonna try and help Ken boost his
self-esteem which will make him a much
better innkeeper ken meet Barbie Barbie
Ken I've flown in Barbie hatch a
Hollywood stylist to give him a new
level it comes a little bit too big for
you let's see it's great it really works
you don't put on a park I just throw it
on your neck get in let's do it Ken's
makeover is finished and I'm gonna take
him out on the town but first let's see
what you start thinking innkeeper very
very nice yeah yes very handsome let's
go
[Music]
I'm taking Ken to a local bar I think
that meeting the right girl will give
them a great confidence boost the sort
of positive energy that will light up
the river rock and make ken a pleasure
to deal with a little place in vitam
until tomorrow rock in yes tomorrow
night yeah we like it tomorrow yeah so
we have a little toast to Kenny
finding a girlfriend over to Kenny come
on it was really great Eagle boost I
felt like the king boy he really set me
up
thank you very much if I fail now I'm
really a loser big date tomorrow good
night
honestly I've never seen a man change so
much let's just hope he's not late for
breakfast in the morning
[Music]